it's main event time oh come on
the script was pretty wild and okay well
he's being tyka I lost Miami like
yesterday so that's still pretty fresh
one of the things that made me really
interested in the film was his use of
music so it made me want to meet him and
we decided we were going to do something
different no idea we were trading
musical ideas back and forth he would
send me things that he liked and I
started writing things for him and he
wanted to bring some synths into it so I
went down in the basement at my
recording studio and I pulled out these
old Devo since it's got a hundred piece
Orchestra but there's about a 50 piece
since things of me and some of the guys
at my studio just going at it on since
what have you brought today tell me a
contender you go to this planet with
Jeff Goldblum and it's the perfect
location to just reinvent you know
sci-fi music IMAX theatres are the best
because there's some things that one
that when I was writing them I want this
gladiator scene between Thor and Hulk I
want the audience to feel like they're
in the middle of the Coliseum with those
guys so we built it so that there's
horns all around you and there's drums
all around you when you're listening to
it you're gonna go oh that's that's
giving me goosebumps
[Music]